dating back to 1886 the texas state fair
is one of the nation's
largest attracting millions of visitors
each year
generations have enjoyed a smorgasbord
all under the watchful eye of a 52-foot
cowboy statue known
as big techs but while the pandemic put
a wrinkle in this year's plans
texans are still enjoying everything the
fair has to offer
while staying safe maria villarreal
has the story howdy
folks it's a texas-sized tradition with
a twist this year
every fall the texas state fair draws
millions to dallas for football
food and fun we always come for the corn
dogs
and turkey legs over the summer the fair
was canceled because of the coronavirus
pandemic
but organizers found a way to bring back
the fun
at a distance so we got a jeep
popped off the top and took a ride
through the new texas state fair
as we enter the state fair they want
very little contact here so this is our
menu
everything just gets brought to us oh my
goodness these look amazing
it's a limited menu with fan favorites
like jack fry's
fletcher's horny dogs have a good day
and cotton candy
thank you and we had to make an extra
stop at smokey john's barbecue for some
official state fair research the smoke
on this is so amazing
juan reeves says the fair opening as a
drive-through this year was
a lifeline for struggling vendors during
the height of covet 19.
it was devastating because the fair
represents about 31
of our annual revenue what does that
translate to as far as jobs
we hire about 125 people it's impacting
people significantly next door is a
state fair staple
sweet connie's corn on the cob happy
fair day guys
during world war ii robin hotchkiss says
her family had to shut down their stand
but resilience is in her blood we're
born and bred to do this
and no state fair visit would be
complete without some classic
fair games we've got all our stuff toys
food probably a stomach ache and
we are done with the drive-through state
fair of texas
drive-throughs are typically described
as a convenient way to get
food fast but this drive-through is
offering
a big bag of nostalgia with a site of
comfort
at a time when all people are craving is
a little bit of normalcy
everybody in our industry has scrambled
but they've found a way
to survive and cope for cbs this morning
saturday
medela villarreal dallas what a great
idea
we like the corn dogs the cotton candy
the barbecue i'm not sure about the hats
yes
an interesting choice